are you thinking of quitting your job
or have you quit your job well you'd
hardly be alone the world of work is
seeing a reshuffle
millions of people around the world quit
their jobs during the pandemic and data
show millions more are thinking of doing
so
entire industries are finding it harder
than ever before to fill up vacancies
and attitudes among workers themselves
are changing
and so people aren't forced to work 40
hours a week at jobs they hate for
people they don't like
for
you know jobs that it couldn't care less
about i think individuals had a lot of
time to sit and reflect and say is my
life trajectory going in the direction i
want so not only did we lose
workers but we're we're not getting
fresh workers in
in this video we ask how has the world
of work changed because of the pandemic
and is that a better world for workers
or a worse one
what do workers want that's all coming
up on this edition of business beyond
now it obviously doesn't make sense to
treat the world of work as a monolith as
if all jobs were the same and the
experience everywhere was similar
in countries like the united states the
united kingdom germany and several
others job vacancies have steadily
increased as the supply of workers
appears unable to keep pace with demand
but these same countries exist in the
same world as those that are
experiencing the opposite problem record
unemployment where millions of people
found themselves jobless and unable to
secure new work especially women and
young people
so it almost goes without saying but
your mileage may vary that doesn't
change the fact that the pandemic has
reached every corner of the world
affecting life as we know it and work as
we've done it and that's manifested in
unique and unprecedented ways you might
be working from home or you might be
vaccinated and back in the office or
alternating between the two or you might
be thinking of even switching to another
job where the conditions suit you better
over the last months you've probably
seen or heard this phrase a lot the
great resignation well here's what that
refers to straight from the person who
came up with it the great resignation is
a spike in the number of people
voluntarily quitting their jobs in the
u.s that we've seen from april of this
year and we have numbers through august
so about 6.7 million more americans quit
their jobs during that time period this
year than last year which makes sense
because last year we were in the middle
of the pandemic
but it's even two million more americans
to quit their jobs during that time
period this year than in 2019 which was
the highest year for voluntary quits on
record and so it's a spike in
resignations that is a bit unexpected
relative to the historical trend lines
since he first used the phrase earlier
in the year as a predictor of a wave of
resignations to come it's become
ubiquitous and it's come to mean
different things depending on who's
using it and where
healthcare workers at the forefront of
the fight against the pandemic were
applauded around the world but are
burning out the international council of
nurses which represents 27 million
nurses in 30 countries has warned that
the so-called intention to leave rate
within a year has doubled to as much as
30 percent
there's also been a spotlight on service
industry and logistics workers who very
often with precarious working conditions
to begin with found themselves
overworked and overwhelmed by surging
demand after the economy reopened
following a period of lockdowns
when we were all in lockdown and we're
all buying online manufacturing goods
was very much in demand so we saw
a shift in workers moving away from
these affected industries to the left
affected industries like manufacturing
but then as the consumer demand shifted
back to services as restrictions were
lifted there then wasn't hospitality
workers or
or people to work within the service
sector because they were very uncertain
about the future of these jobs if there
was further lockdowns um and so and they
just had moved
all together away from these areas so
then it left us with a huge gap when
consumer patterns changed once again
others think more of workers resisting
being called back into the office after
having worked from home and for whom
anything other than a hybrid model of
working no longer makes sense so i think
the great resignation is where people
who have
enjoyed being at home more during covert
and are going back into jobs that aren't
offering them their flexibility are
choosing to leave and do something else
you know the the the title suggests that
they're resigning and going and doing
nothing which i don't think is the case
in march this year microsoft released
its work trend index 2021 survey that's
a survey among around 30 000 full-time
or self-employed workers across 31
markets and it said that 41 of those
surveyed said they were considering
leaving their jobs
not surprising perhaps because the
pandemic amplified existing challenges
around work in other words it became
even harder to work so you might have
had this in your workplace you might
have for various pandemic related
reasons fewer people to work with
leaving the rest of you with a much
bigger workload than you would normally
have which leads to your co-workers
burning out and leaving leaving the rest
of you with a bigger workload than you
would normally have and so on so the
pandemic was unique that it kind of
burned out almost everybody in some ways
and we know burnout is a predictor of
turnover
but the frontline workers who were in
healthcare retail food service during
the pandemic were reporting high levels
of burnout
organizational managers and executives
who were leading their organizations
through the pandemic were really
stressed and although there's a lot of
upsides to remote work there were many
caregivers who were juggling
responsibilities personally
professionally child care and so forth
that were reporting high levels of
burnout at the same time border closures
and coveted restrictions hampered
migration
meaning there were just fewer workers
around especially in industrialized
nations as it became harder to travel to
them
seen quite a lot of disruption to
migrant inflows so a lot of countries
around the world are very dependent on
migrant labor to be able to
conduct the activities they want to
conduct and so
in at the start of the pandemic we saw
outflows of migrant workers
but we also have seen across the
pandemic disruptions continued
disruption to the inflows of migrant
workers so not only did we lose
workers but where we're not getting
fresh workers in
and that means companies are having to
dig deeper into their pockets to retain
people or recruit them in the first
place
you see the major impact of neighbour
shortages is the upward pressure on wage
growth
so that is the immediate impact of the
laboratory that we're seeing we've seen
many countries are having to or many
companies are having to um
bring with hiring large bonuses to uh to
lure people to the professions or
or just to find any workers at all
that's good news for workers and in fact
the current moment of labor shortages
and elevated resignations are being
framed as a moment where in-demand
workers find themselves with more
leverage bargaining power and motivation
to organize workers at starbucks for
example voted to unionize for the first
time in the u.s that's triggered hopes
of a revitalized labor movement in the
country but some experts fear that not
all the positive gains may stick rising
wages for one may eventually level off
and if they are granted more wages where
is that passed on to and the data at the
moment given the levels of inflation
that we're experiencing suggests it's
being passed on to the customers once we
move out of the transition phase that
we're in into something more permanent
everything suggests that more people are
actually going to be at home so probably
a less of demand for the services that
are experiencing the wage increases at
the moment worth noting that not
everything is about pay the pandemic
forced changes to the shape of working
life enabled by technology and not
everyone is willing to revert back to
the way things used to be
here in europe a survey of 14 000 people
from december showed that only 14 of
european workers want to come back to
in-office work from nine to five
experts predict that that will mean
companies who do want physical presence
may have to pay extra for it but that in
turn could have unintended consequences
some companies who can afford to pay
will give compensating differentials
just to bring people back into the
office right so if you if you if you
take this top process through if the
women who are leaving organizations the
value presenteeism and being in the
office
are the ones that value flexibility and
hybrid working and they find a home in
another company probably with less pay
because you pay a compensating
differential for hybrid working firstly
the gender gap will widen then we wonder
why and nobody will really be able to
nail this down because it's impossible
to nail down in data in other words some
workers say working mothers or disabled
people might value flexibility over
money
they might not stay in companies that
would pay to keep their employees in the
office preferring to take the pay cut
that could exacerbate wage divides and
make companies with more traditional
working models less diverse
but it's not just how much or how little
flexibility within a job that has become
more important to workers over the
pandemic
for many people the pandemic also
triggered an internal reconfiguring of
values and questions as to where work
belonged in that new configuration do i
need to be in the office all the time or
do i even need to have such an extreme
dependent kind of job or a job that
takes a lot of the time so yes we
certainly are seeing the impact of
labour availability
if people are um
are just moving away from different job
choices or that they are just retiring
early that's certainly something we've
seen in many countries that
we've got an aging workforce as it is
anyway i think individuals had a lot of
time to sit and reflect and say is my
life trajectory going in the direction i
want am i happy do i have a sense of
purpose someone else coined the term
pandemic epiphanies and i thought it was
a good one to capture
how people were reassessing the place of
work in their lives deciding i want to
spend more time with family after the
pandemic i want to spend more time
pursuing my hobbies and other aspects of
myself outside of work
in other words the pandemic has gotten
people asking themselves why they're
alive and for some mostly to work isn't
really the answer they've come up with
you might have heard of the anti-work
subreddit that's a subreddit for those
who want to end work are curious about
ending work one to get the most out of a
work free life want more information on
anti-work ideas and want personal help
with their own jobs work related
struggles
they saw membership surge this year with
posts relating to quitting jobs being
especially popular
to give a sort of context to this we had
around 189 000 last year in about uh in
october of last year
we now have 1.2 million people uh so the
uptick has been incredible
uh i think optic is probably
underselling it uh as a as a moderator
um but yeah i
you know i was very surprised when all
this was happening i felt uh but at the
same time i wasn't so tell us what's
your dream job darling i've told you
several times before i have no dream job
i do not dream of labor
the pandemic has forced a discussion on
the value of labor but not just in a
transactional sense it's helped
accelerate a rethink of society's
relationship with work some have pointed
out there's a historical precedent to a
pandemic triggering a systemic overhaul
the black death or the plague is thought
to have effectively ended feudalism a
drastically reduced population meant
there was less labor to go around serfs
found themselves in demand and less tied
to the estates employing them and the
gap between have-nots like peasants and
halves like landlords eventually became
less and less defined that's obviously
radically oversimplified and not exactly
what's happening now but the
re-examination of hustle culture in
countries like the us or the rise of the
so-called lying flat movement in china
indicates that the notion of work as a
good in itself is not as obvious as it
once was as rising housing prices and
recurring financial crises make the
gains from dedicated workaholism less
apparent to me i mean anti-work is a
philosophy that is aiming to
uh ideally reduce to zero uh as much
coercive work as possible um you know
that coercive element of it is really
the most important part
um and so people aren't forced to work
40 hours a week at jobs they hate for
people they don't like for
you know jobs that it couldn't care less
about
um and for wages that are unfair usually
in uh
usually in bad environments but the
anti-work movement isn't exactly new
is bob black in the abolition of work
from 1985.
no one should ever work
work is the source of nearly all the
misery in the world almost any evil
you'd care to name comes from working or
from living in a world designed for work
in order to stop suffering we have to
stop working
maybe not all the misery are any evil in
any case stopping work isn't really an
option for that many people but stopping
suffering and promoting well-being
definitely is there's more to life than
just work and there's a certain
privilege in being able to say that
families have to be supported living
costs have to be covered futures have to
be secured but that is perhaps precisely
the point that in a fairer world
everybody should be able to say that the
pandemic isn't over so it's hard to say
how the world has permanently changed
but it's even harder to imagine things
going back to the way they were people
are simply much more aware now that work
is about the people who do it and much
more conscious about the systems that
govern it
we have the opportunity to change
almost everything when it comes to how
we arrange work let's do it in a way
that's fair and equitable
for everyone and fix some of the
systemic problems we had
before the pandemic and that's it for
this edition of business beyond if you
enjoyed this video please do check out
our other content hit like and subscribe
thank you very much for watching